[Music]
yeah hello everyone my name is Leo I'm
not
Bhargav unfortunately Bhargav couldn't
come today with my name is layoffs I'm
the maintainer of Jenson I'll give a
talk on word embeddings which is not
gonna be topic modeling but still going
to be jensen and nature language further
think things like that this is the repo
called movie plus by genre today we'll
analyze movie plots and automatically
find that runner using words of a queue
mainly and try to relative please find
the repo and clone it it's the new
there's some notebooks inside it some of
them already have outputs if you want to
cheat or you can just find out books and
notebooks don't have output the main
ones here called docume crucification
the word abetting yeah and this is the
one you should follow through nobodies
if you want some surprises huh yeah I'll
right there I've shortened it as a URL
so I write it on the board right now
little are
the DNR let's see there I didn't know it
was the same yeah also some slides
government it
okay so how much time do we have when I
supposed to finish it in 30 minutes
cool yeah we could infer the minutes
that's possible so first uh you know oh
yeah so my name is Leia from community
manager like you know you don't probably
care about me much that I'll do two
parts today first one I'll do some
cereal for Tyvek and secondly we'll run
some codes while you're cloning the repo
while you're not setting it up then I'll
just do some talking cool so then same
how many of you have used Jensen before
one two three good it's a tutorial so
that's the right level to be it so
Jensen is this open source topic
modeling can board a bedding project you
know we have about 500 academic
citations now and at the same time we
have a lot of industry adopters so we
have you know like Cisco Amazon this
kind of people use the software and this
is very nice place to be it intersection
of Industry in academia we take sound
paper look at the code that comes with
paper and has you know variables called
ADC no comments like nothing like that
virgin in C and we try to make it into a
Python code which is maintainable you
know has nice variable names you know
actually some comments and something
that people can maintain over the years
and using production so that's what we
do yeah like most of the stuff is done
throwing a beta program with students
and Bhargav yeah well gov is here yeah
mrs. Vargas was supposed to give the
tutorial this morning and you know we
have most users if they're students here
and you want to work on open source
please get in touch
she just gets free mentoring from us
half an hour a week of skype 100 [ __ ]
cool related so I'll talk about work
back today and why would you care about
words back algorithm and mainly because
it's magical like this is a magical
application of this algorithm somebody
took a lot of restaurants abused so the
company in San Francisco about 2,000
restaurants in this small city and they
found out things about restaurants just
from reviews there's no notation just
completely unsupervised learning so they
come up with this recommender so you
could start with vanilla steakhouse and
say I would like something more jazzy
and you get
to have a vanilla steakhouse plus
selector for jazz and it gets a
steakhouse with live chats or you know
you start vanilla Steakhouse add
something Google scenic and get
steakhouse with you we want to add
effect from starts vector for usual
Steakhouse and add a vector for a patio
and you had a vector you know just end
up with something Weaver has a patio and
put you in a view at two different
restaurants of course I didn't know but
yeah and the other uses for this
technique of word embeddings you know
you can automatically tag the text as
we're gonna do today today we will have
a movie plot come in and the outcome
will be genre of the movie plot it's
going to be romanced action or drama
something like that and you can also use
for convention recommendation engines
and you've just seen with the
restaurants you can also do it for a
search query expansion originally this
algorithm came from Google and Google
used it for expanding the search queries
you know like when you type something in
a task queue did you mean something else
that's word to that because one of the
things working behind the scenes here
machine translation you know just plain
feature engineering many uses for this
stuff
cool so the the notebook that is
available at this URL movie plot by
genre this is what it does so imagine if
you were on a movie studio and you have
thousands of proposals for movies and
need to classify them some way need to
send it to right Department for
consideration you know like one
department for genre and this is a you
know artificial problem in reality every
time I give this workshop there's
somebody in the room who classifies its
regiments OCS and to society know which
job they should go to you know this is a
Java Sea view it's the fighting to you
you know what is this so that the
scientists agree what should I send it
to or like somebody might classify spam
this way or you know support forum
request there's so many applications how
we need to classify text into different
fields and we're going to do one about
movie plots because it's more fun cool
so the main tool we're going to use
today is a word embedding and what is
the word embedding this warda Bannock is
just a way to assign a vector to the
word
and you know the easiest way to assigned
a vector to words they have a vocabulary
so having a million words in my
vocabulary and I say that the word King
is the word number one so I just turned
on the bit one and rest of them as yours
and I say the way with Queen is the word
number two so just turn on the second
bit in rest measure it's called one hot
embedding only one bit is hot at the
time and this is okay the only problem
is that my vectors are 1 million long
that way and very sparse and it's
annoying to I mean of course I can store
sparse moon lectures memory but it still
it feels like a waste waste of space and
then if I want to find if king and queen
are related there's no way I can do it
you know what like it's kind of like I
don't even know if there's any
relationship between the words this way
so a word embedding or word vector or
distribute representation is this thing
this thing is much shorter right and
only has 3 dimensions have like 0.94 3
57 and 0 22 and here I don't have a
million dimensions anymore I have only
free so it's much much more dense lower
dimensional representation and the
reason it's called distributed is
because the meaning is distributed
across all the free dimension here the
meaning of King is concentrated in the
first dimension in the meaning of Queen
excite in the second here the meaning of
King is distributed across all the free
and the vector for Queen will be quite
similar to this one and then I can do
the products of them I can do some kind
of similarity measures between them and
you know see if words are related or not
so yeah this is what we're going to
construct today today we're going to
find some algorithms which will give me
a good numbers like y0 94 is a good
number for Kings like the certainty
pissed I'm like why is it a good number
so we're gonna they were going to talk
about how to construct this kind of yeah
exactly which does Dalton this financial
space of the word it's more like not
like each note is the word but each word
is a dot because I mean it took that
continued some serial numbers
cool so to do this to define out with
good numbers I need to know something
about the words you know and the yeah I
need to know something about my domain
and into
some assumptions and the assumption we
use Hippolytus from linguistics
it's called distributional Hippolytus
and you know about the man they say like
you should know a man by the company he
keeps the same thing about no words they
shall know avoid by the company it keeps
example I want to find out the meaning
of banking and computers never going to
find the meaning of banking law if you
have it in a head
well it's going to find out is that
banking like the company of government
like the company of regulation like the
company of crisis you know that's all
we're going to find out about it you're
not going to be talking to Bloomberg
well yeah this is only find out that and
this is like idea from Lincoln Stein it
a word is just the way use it what it's
by itself has no meaning the word is
defined by how people use it you know if
you use my name in different context
you'll no longer be my name for example
yeah and this is a what what is we're
going to use to create this vector
vector and of course you know usually
procedure to come up with something in
machine learning nowadays you you know
start up to randomly have some objective
function that you improve on and then do
gradient descent on that until you know
your boss tells you it's time to submit
and this is the objective function I'm
not going to talk about it more like I
would slogan is topic modeling for
humans like not for mathematicians so
like I'll do some hand wavy explanation
of it like if you want to know more just
go to this course yesterday for D or
there's a nice deep mind oxford course
about energy you like just do that if
you want to know more about math but
this is you know too short time to talk
about nasty cool so there let's pretend
that I'm this algorithm called vert avec
and I just see this sentence the folks
jumped over lazy dog I need to make some
conclusions about the words that I see
so I want to find about the meaning of
the word over and what I really do is I
have a bunch of probabilities in my head
so I privilege of two words appearing
together and if I see them appear
together in the same sentence then I
bump them up so I have over appeared as
a friend of all these words so let's
increase all those probabilities
you know privilege of that given over is
going to become higher but the
even over it can become higher so every
time I see this you know but every time
I just see a ward I go through all of
its neighbors and bump up this
probabilities and this is just a for
loop you know I fix one one word and for
loop over all its neighbors and just
bump up probability of you know over
give they're given over of folks given
over John given over and they given over
laser given over dog being over
yeah all these things this is one for
loop and another for loop is it goes
over all the words at the center Lord
and then I look at old friends of the
word there so I give like a privilege of
day given there is higher
you know folks given there is higher and
then bump up all of them that's how it
works there's no neural networks or
anything like that just to for loops you
know just take the Central Ward then go
for all this neighbors wanted to dunno
the neighbors move to the next word and
look at all the neighbors of that and I
just go for entire data set that I have
in the same in this fashion
yeah the only tricky part here is to
define this probability I have two
vectors you know one list of three
numbers and a list of three numbers how
to get the probability out of that you
have any ideas huh
sort of like three numbers here if you
remove their sex or should I count
distance you got a Canadian distance but
it could be like you know from minus
infinity it could be like minus 100 or
plus 100 good positive positive it could
be like zero to Hunter like 120,000
let's not hit probability good for like
the distance in the proof for the first
segment yeah this is one thing it could
work what they end up doing is taking a
cosine distance so imagine you first you
you take you have all these vectors in
the space for us to project them onto
the unit sphere so make them all you
know
length one so you'll end up on the unit
sphere on this year I just measure the
angle between them and that gives me the
cosine distance and it's very easy to
calculate that's the dot product it's
like the simplest thing you can do have
you know three numbers here from is
there multiply the first one by the
first one second by the second one for
by the third one and add them all
together that's all you do and then you
divide by the norm just to normalize it
but what's the range of cosine okay so
that's not probability yet so now I have
to do something about it like maybe
sigmoid but they just decided to do self
marks this was the simplest thing to do
and start max tells you what's special
between you know what special between
folks if I have you know folks and jump
here and I divided by folks and over
folks and they and divided by focuses
all the other words now find out what is
so special about folks and jump it's
compared to all the other word
combinations that are there this is what
softmax does for you just e to the power
dot product divided by the sum over all
the other words all the words so that
whether I see what's special about this
particular pair of words let me the
probability of folks and jump appearing
together cool do you have any questions
so far about the theory
mm-hmm so the so I start with some
random vectors initially and I have a
objective function and I see how it you
know I do a pass over the corpus let see
I see how well it fits and and it's just
the usual you know back propagation that
way I just have a correction to the
gradient descent on that objective
function thank you so they start some
randomly in a slowly minimize my
objective function and by minimize I'm
second function I maximize the
probability of words that I see
appearing together so I start first
start up quite random then I calculate
you know for folks and jump I calculate
this probability and I see that it is
lower than it should be so I have to
increase it if I see them together let's
sort of call the gradient descent works
but specifically the objective function
is yeah yeah this is the objective
function you have this log of
probability where probability is defined
using this the self marks and this is
what I take the derivative false and do
the Graduate assembly did answer your
question okay cool so just as usual you
start up randomly and then you do the
gradient ascent and there are some
parameters of course like you have a
learning rate and you know number of
passes that you want to do the corpus
just as it usually happens cool so now
how has seen this picture before okay
half of the room good okay so you know
what Vorta Beck is like every talking
word to that maths had this picture in
it and this is about this pink vector of
femininity so you end up with this cool
vector where you take a word for woman
and subtract it with the word for men so
in that footage this vector which makes
things more feminine and I can go to
King and make King my feminine now end
up with Queen and this is this a side
product of this procedure it's not
exactly obvious how it came along
because we didn't really you know
optimize for this but this is just a
nice side product and this is how this
recommendations work in the beginning
you know
we had vanilla steakhouse and they got
the director for jazz we end up with a
John Steakhouse like what I mean how I
just dinner like like two different
kinds of analogies always in the sense
of the directions like like here it
works for gender like doesn't work for
rivers or Airlines or something like
that um it does work I never seen a
production system built it that's that's
the problem
a parts on this recommendation thing
which has they know hand-picked
recommended specifically chose you know
jazz and view and patio they didn't
choose like anywhere that you can answer
it so it works quite well for these
directions it doesn't work well for you
know answer names for example if I add
you know two words a different meaning
what I get is kind of meaningless so it
is you have to be a bit you have to do
some hand picking if you want to use in
production that's true yeah but it's a
good point and it's not exactly
explained what is the math behind it but
we is that this structure is produced
more obvious in glove than in here in a
different emetic cool so okay I
described just now is a unsupervised
algorithm and there's no labeling needed
you just fit put some rotate rotate into
it and this board vectors come out and
Google ran its own you know 100 billion
fun labeled Wars just took all in use
they could find ran internet for a long
time and put this model online and this
is one model that you can play with
online yeah you can go to this URL and
play
yeah so here's example of you know man
is the king as women is to Queen and you
know yeah you can do things like that
yep
so better they want to find something
that has closest things so I have to you
know maximize
the misery I'm so I'm trying to find a
maximum vector let's call it you know V
such that its dot product with this
combination of vectors man plus King
ma'am woman I think it should be like
women plus King - man yeah let's King -
man yeah so the V Queen is something
which is close to women far away from
man but also close to king and it's a
dot product that product is linear so
basically I want you know V dot women to
be big I want you know the dots king to
be big too and I want you know V dot man
to be small that's what it's all it
means and I just find a maximum of this
I find just want to find a vector which
is satisfied as all of this at the same
time and it will be something it's not
exactly there it's in the neighborhood
of that just like wherever what is the
closest vector in there right did answer
your question sort of yeah but it's not
going to be exactly there it's not true
yeah it's going to be somewhere in there
there's probably the emptiness where it
is but around it the closest vector will
be that but it's not just closest to
that point but it's you're really
satisfying three conditions at the same
time they're just forming linearity of
dot product that's that's two other
magic is the can you guess what will
happen if I put here say in here any
guesses huh
it's a it's a trademark lawsuit yep cool
cool
so let's go okay we have some I think
about 15 minutes to go let's go through
some ransom code they've even been able
to load the repo please them in the
browser
okay I'm gonna be able to load it in
there Jupiter notebooks yeah cool one
two three four five awesome
okay you um so let me introduce the
problem first yeah so this is we're
going to try to figure out today like
what's the genre of the plots so what's
the gender of this plot specifically can
you tell me I want to give a human
baseline how good at humans at this task
sci-fi this is actually I don't know
some of you might have seen this movie
it's from 1995
yeah Bruce Willis and Brad Pitt and
there's definitely sci-fi yeah it's
called you know twelve Monkeys and why I
think it's sci-fi is because it talks
about the future you know has some virus
you know a planet there's some specific
words in here to make it total sound
like sci-fi so it must be some signal in
here like there must be some hope like
sci-fi movie plots to complete different
words from you know romantic movie plot
like and this is a romantic movie plot
yeah I gave it away but it is a romantic
my book yeah like you can see that this
talks about well you know about
daughters about to know much in marriage
things like that so it should be
something going here
they should be able to separate as if
you know with some kind of NLP technique
and yeah it's called Sense and
Sensibility
that is the movie plot which obviously
magic cool the main problem is data set
that we have is that it's unbalanced in
most things that committee after 2000
reports you know most things are comedy
the problem with it is it's small like
100 K is really small like 500k boards
is the minimum that you need to run this
imports of AK model so yes you want 2000
words it's quite small that's the
problem but you know for something to
run in your laptop you know right here
it should be okay okay so there let's
run some code okay I'll be I'll be
cheating I'll show you some not life
running but just some I can be with
authority cool so this already have seen
just you know just exploring the data
and so it's a good at a scientist I will
start with the stupidest baseline I can
think of you know and the stupidest
baseline actually I was the triplets
baseline you can think of if you look at
this plot what is the easiest baseline
to come up with networking is comedy
what's the accuracy of it I could use
merely like forty percent accuracy
yeah like forty percent of my stuff is
already already comedy that's already
good enough that's what I'm trying to
beat forty percent okay next stupid
algorithm in Ooty is just bag of words
and Douga words this is count how many
times the word love appear in my plot
how many know and if it's a lot of love
then probably be romance or how many
times is the word in a future appear so
the future will be sci-fi it's all I do
just count the words in my lot and you
know that's what I try to do and and
then that is delicious the aggression to
figure out which which part it comes
into and my teachers are like that like
adventure adventures adventures you know
I freaked out they said the words is I'm
going to count I'm going to count all
the words I only count the most frequent
ones they probably have more information
but not the very frequent and that gives
me accuracy of what does it give me give
me accuracy of 42 percent I think people
who are running it can be been able to
reproduce this
yeah I think that just just the
counseling boards use me 42% and but
this is 46 and 46 is because I do tf-idf
and don't even know here what Jeff IDF
is okay cool that this probably you need
some explaining that you know it's like
if one movie plot has the word lab at
Pier five times but the movie plot is
you know 10,000 words long probably
doesn't mean that it's about love it
just means it's five only five times
appears that's not a big deal
if the movie plot is only 100 words long
if it's really small and the word love
is five of them that's actually really
important so that's the FDF is a way to
adjust it by document length and also I
adjusted by how rare or frequent this
term is just a more clever way to count
words and then gives me better accuracy
you know gives you 46 percent accuracy
and I use this simple sq learn tf-idf
vectorizer
things where I only look at words that
appear in two documents it appears in
less than two documents to throw them
away
yeah and I use the English stuff words
stop words are just the words that have
no meaning the word well that has a
meaning but it's a 4/4 move applause
they don't have any meaning because
what's that all the words like there are
soft words which appear a lot very
frequently but doesn't mean don't mean
anything special so just throw them away
the starting technique and an LP to
throw away stop words this is the
confusion matrix for this thing so you
have happy as anybody you think of you
could anybody not seeing confusion
matrix before it's a wrong way to ask a
question okay yeah but it's like in
fusion metrics and it's very nice for a
classifier like anytime you're
classifying things just plot it and you
can see this is what my model things on
the horizontal axis and true label is
what's the actual true labels are so
sci-fi is quite blue means that a lot of
factual Syfy's went to size
and comedy you know comedy 2 comedy
sky-blue but my model also thinks that
animation is comedy and prowl animation
is actually comedy it probably means I
should go back to the business and tell
and while your label is not right and
you know six months later women have to
come some agreement
yeah so this is a real problem you know
animation cover they are the same but I
have to predict them so yeah so my
labels are not so good that's what I can
tell from this model from there from
this graph maybe it's just because my
model think that everything is comedy
like it sends you know action to comedy
and firefighter comedy
so maybe it just being lazy just thinks
that everything is comedy and lots of
everything and maybe that's the problem
cool this is my one bed line so now I
want to use birth of X so let's come to
the punchline of this talk and I showed
you how to get the vector for every word
but now we have 100 words you know
future planets and they'll come together
how do I get the vector for them how
that puts I forget something that I put
in the classifier so they have any ideas
like how do you get one vector out of
100 vectors I can roll to the scientists
you should know how to do the average
you know that's like the first thing I
do I have a hundred things to do that
bridge just an average of them and
that's actually works quite well I mean
I won't you know sometimes you can even
get this thing where you can just add
all the words in a book and then you get
the main idea in that book yeah let's
try it actually it should work in
reality so yep if you just
if I have some code for that
[Music]
so this is what I try to do this and it
don't work so this is my movie plot
mister the main ideas to chat in this
movie you know okay so this is about
some piano teacher and it's something
romantic and somehow I see the main idea
is just and button in like that's that's
meaningless exactly what happened to
stop words so there's an exercise you
know remove stop words so to remove stop
words you get that show like get love
and the cooler and you know more
interesting words so that's that that's
the exercise that you can try at home
just do this thing it's removing the
stuff words and you'll get something
much money in English but this words are
meaningless to me yeah but and if you
remove them you'll get something
meaningful out of it
cool yeah that's the summarization okay
so give you only one word does the main
idea not like to a free I'm going to be
like an actual title header just the
gist of it and they're like sample Yahoo
uses this for storage query
disambiguation I just you know the div
or everything you put in the search
query every vector for that average that
and figure out what's the main main
intent of the if they're surgically make
the search magic mean yeah just IRA
fighting it's all quite linear here like
because of that the relationship is
worth quite well because you want to
find something which is close to you
know three words if you like you know
just say like women plus kink has to be
something close to women and close to
king at the same time so this arithmetic
mean works quite well that's because of
the linearity of dot product yeah
there's no word order really there's
only the context like we know have
awards and this with its neighbors these
are ten neighbors I don't know which one
is closer which one is further away
there's no waiting in there yeah it's
the word order is mainly thrown away
this apart from the window like the
window is like minus 5 or plus 5 and
I'll give a talk on Sunday about how to
choose the window window parameter in
your words back like you know if you use
a big window it small when they actually
get different meanings of this of the
words of the vectors this will be a
Sunday talk about how to tune your the
betting's and yeah she around them
something cool there is this is all
being quite you know naive way like the
average is kind of silly thing to do
there is a more advanced way to get
vectors for documents I'll just go it
over like the next last you know two
minutes and I will go into question and
it's called dr. Beck it's also came from
Google from the same authors that did
were to back paper and there you
actually like it becomes sort of sinus
supervised drink training I have to tell
it
what's the genre of my of this specific
movie plot but it's not the only
objective you know it has to come up
with vectors awards and has a clump of
get vectors for comedy so it's um it's
quite as it's not completely supervisors
console completely unsupervised becomes
assignments it devised algorithm it's
probably confusing pretty forgettable so
I have this idea of tags and tag is a
board which is in every context on the
dog so example I say this is a comedy
plot like the folks jumped over the lazy
dog it's a funny sentence at the comedy
part so every time I look at a context
of the word of the word folks I actually
will have over this neighbor will also
have comedy at its neighbor and comedies
will become a vector in my space and you
know the same way as I have yeah like
have you know King living here I have
the word comedy living here and then I
also have you know comedy tag putting in
here I'll have like a special become a
special vector in my space just will
live there and there's a way I can
arrive on them and to figure out that
they're close to one another just to
have you know yeah okay just a second
and the way I arrived at this vectors is
just you know by doing the for loop as I
did doing before you know just go for
every word and say that its neighbors
are you know over in comedy that's right
yeah the question see I have a word
comedy and I have a comedy tag so it's
live it lives in the same space it's
just it's a vector but it's not the same
as if you know I had you know the comedy
and jumped over the lazy dog it I will
have a I'll have to it's in the same
vector space but it's not the same as
the word comedy interesting separate as
I called the tag and it's fit in a
different way yeah it's in that same
space like I it's actually quite nice
that they're all in the same space
because it means I can see which words I
close this to comedy and it huh it's a
different color yeah I use a different
color uh-huh yeah and also moves comedy
around they both move yep
yeah okay it just has a different color
in there and this is quite nice that
they all live in the same space because
I can do things like you know closest
words to sci-fi so sci-fi is the stag
and I can see one of the closest words
to it so I can see this alien you know
Express space like this words that
describe sci-fi and it's quite nice I
can get descriptions for them I can have
as many tags as possible I can have you
know sometimes you know can be a
username or you know you can make them
into it types can be anything you have
you know 10 tags to the same text and
find out information about it that way
just so very descriptive thing to do so
I can see which words are closest to
sci-fi but and I can also see which
genres are closest to each other
so this is I only look at the red
vectors here does they forget about the
green words only look at the red one so
romance closer sphincter manses fantasy
that makes sense you know
suspense as you like lurk and it is like
romance of elves basically and then the
action is really far away and that makes
sense but action is far away from mm and
this is done on just a small two hundred
thousand you know words that I said
that's way cool yeah I really like this
thing that causes in a war story months
it's just like yeah it's like
millionaire and local and hair yeah this
is what defines romantic runner yeah
question so I only end up with this big
special vectors so I only have yeah out
of two thousand plots I only get six
special lectures it's one way to do it
you can also do it for every document
it's possible you have like document one
document to the country and then you can
have descriptions for that that's also
possible
it just doesn't give that many that
that's good results in here because the
documents are quite short like they're
not long enough to find they find out
something about them specifically
yeah yeah I could have like you know da
Quan talking here yeah and dr. yeah I
could do that yeah have you used that in
your project somehow kinda okay this is
yeah another question yeah like comedic
comedy animation yeah I can have as many
as I want
yeah I can have like doc 1 comedy
romance you know ya know Lev likes it
yeah I can have like anything you want
so that yeah the number of tigers not
it's not limited just cool yeah and dr.
that gives me something slightly better
it gives me 52 percent so the stupid
deadline everything is comedy was 40
doctor back this fancy thing with tags I
get 32 percent so this better you know
it's still things that everything is
comedy like this is really blew it still
sends everything to comedy you know it
takes the well 25 seconds to drain in
James I'm dr. Beck just one line you
know just give it two sentences they use
to Fred 100 use a hundred dimensions
that's how long my vectors are going to
be size 100 222 raishin and you know and
use the J mount good how good and then I
just do the problem is prediction the
prediction prediction time have a new
vac I have a new plot that comes in and
it's just a bunch of words it just has
the green tags in it and I have to come
up with a red tag for it and that's
that's where it's annoying I have to run
gradient descent to find out what's the
best red sock that fits it actually have
to do this objective function
minimization again to find out what's
that that works for that and if you run
several times to get different vectors
so like this you know this 52 percent
accuracy like sometimes I get it 42 so
then I get it 67 and the changes every
time you run it the
because I mean if you strain it well if
you have a big corporate everything is
fine but this is a tiny toy example and
it's it's annoying you have a group
random as a prediction time like how
many classifiers you know that a
prediction time gets you give you random
results like not so many so this is
peculiar here but the key model is big
enough and it gets stable and you know
it's all gets fine no like this is 100
dimensional this time like huh they're
all in the same space so the documents
one-hundredth long and the words 100
long as well they both live in the same
space 100 I mention all space the three
dimensions it was just an easy example
before because I could like to talk
about it
typically a hundred yeah 100 is the
typical action number yeah that's what
was in the source paper and since then
it became the standard thing to do the
Google were one has been trained on you
know billions of words that's 300
dimensions the one it's you know sort of
king men and queen yeah it's just a
divot gradient descent really there's
nothing else in there just we have a
just it's just like any other radius and
works like you have a learning rate and
you try to you know take derivatives
here and you you know just decide which
is slowly going to go down and mainly
its initial initial initialization is
random so like how do I come up with a
have a new plot come in say you know
like dock 1 and I want to find out where
does doc wants it and I randomly
initialized here then I start moving
gets around and financialized it
somewhere else that would prob'ly end up
with a different you know local minimum
yeah it does the problem is random
initialization of gradient descent
algorithm that's that sort is the
negative sampling yet does add some
randomness but it's not not not in the
prediction of dr. back in a different
case
cool so okay so we have like one minute
to finish right right
and I organized this here huh X I have
extra time well it's a text of time for
questions and just finish them so if you
look in a notebook somewhere at home you
find more a bunch of other advanced
algorithms here and you see that what
they what we get from them and the best
one the winner is this averaging thing
just take the words and average them
that's been that's the winner
give me whooping fifty-eight percent
accuracy like well forty is everything
is comedy but you cheat and that's not
very impressive you know like I heard
about neural networks the DOE amazing
things you know and even for loops can
do amazing things like why doesn't it
work and the reason doesn't work is
because I have to tune it you need a lot
of data and have to tune it and tuning
any each one of the documents will take
another like hour and a half to talk
about just all the hyper parameters that
it has and how to choose the right
window signs right iterations alpha and
all this thing and but out of the box
you don't get nice results if you want
to unite results you can read a paper
which solves you 98% accuracy you know
they'd spend two months you know tuning
it that's that's that's the you know the
short outcome of this this talk you know
the training time is not really that big
for most of them and prediction time is
only bad for like one one of those
algorithms
yep yeah and just a multi-class logistic
regression just have you know five six
runners as my output I think I do use
some liquor ization yeah so that just
because I have a lot of them yeah ever I
go today mm-hmm just attach three
hundred numbers input and Buddha
logistics and just aggression and it
comes out maybe if I used to run the
forest I would get something better
let's wanted to use something quick as a
classifier like yeah
yep there are some dimensions in there
and it's sort of and it's still this
average vector it still exists in the
same four headed dimensional vector
space as everything else an averaging
works quite similar like if only Steve
average of women and King aisle had
something which is close to room and and
close to King so I can still to look at
the neighbors of it and the
summarization example we saw the
summarization where gives me the main
meaning of the of the plot and that's
exactly I just took take the average of
them and find what's the closest words
to that average so this time still some
meaning in there however if I do TCA
this will slowly improve like if I do
TCA before doing the classifier this
will improve so there's some some
meaningful ways to get more meaning to
desert dimensions but but the general is
rotation invariant and when it first
comes out the cosine is rotation
variances put them all in unit sphere
let's look at the angle between them I
don't really care about or two
orthogonal I see and this in here the
car don't you see I get bad results
yeah that's a good question so this is a
different line this is the dr. Beck line
so here I'll my input into logistic
reaction will not be the average of this
words like given it has the Nome King in
comedy I'll just ignore this green words
we're only give it the red label and
let's label would be like doc one so
this is the only input will be just the
doc label that comes in so I give it all
the words then ever and gradient is sent
to find out what's the best doc one
which fits it what's the best red label
that fix it and then I put this red
label into logistic if you're if you
look at the code you'll find medicals
there okay and the thing there's another
question in the back yep antonyms are
quite hard and negation is quite hard
[Music]
and you can do if phrases before that if
you have like note lab appearing a lot
there's algorithms you'll just see like
oh this towards a few frequently
together let's make it not underscore
lab and that will be like a one word in
there
so if you do this you know just do
underscore it's like concatenate
frequent by grams beforehand then it
you'll figure it out that's not but it
will think of not lab as a different
words from well yeah but in visual
antonyms don't work that way
unfortunately cool so I'll just I'll
just finish and then you ask more or
less more questions in end so there's no
net magic out of the books you know and
what does this models would easiest for
you to debug in tune like if I send them
all of the clients they you know take
some email Lee just wrote to you know
their partner put it in my model and
comes out to some stimulus and email me
like why does it happen it's like oh you
know Google train and model that way you
know in the paper it's not really an
answer usually in consulting you can
give them or like you know why
why does this think everything is comedy
you know what can I do to make it less
you know what kind to fix this class of
errors and what's the easiest model out
of all of them to fix that and this is
the easiest one
the tf-idf Doug rewards my features are
just words you know like adventure
adventurous you know love planets I can
easily do them you know like oh maybe I
should remove the word love and then it
will work better like I can actually
explain what's happening there
everything else is black box and hard so
if it's up to me I will just use the F
at the F all day
you know I don't get your talks on PI
data about the F at the efforts Omicron
well yeah well if it was up to me I
would you Stepford yes consulting you
can only create the accuracy and create
your tunings and just use simple model
and it will be fine and will be quite
self-explanatory cool yep this is easy
to debug Anna just understand yesterday
I bag of words tomorrow huh
um I haven't tried it as data set but it
is much easier to do it so then there's
something else
yeah I could probably get it to 57 yeah
if I play more of my features and like
an amplifier down sample the comedy
genre in training metal give me already
something something better here yeah I
think I think it's possible but you can
the data isn't github like if you submit
the pull request which shows if I do
have beat everything I'll be happy yeah
cool yeah I mean it still place where
the Bennigsen the world like when you
want some small improvements now when
you have gigabytes of data and like you
know a million awards that would help a
lot or if you want to some extra
features to you exactly already have
tf-idf add more feature maybe you get
something better
yeah let's tell a place were debating
don't completely ignore that stuff just
it's not should mean that should be like
your first you know thing you go to let
the ideal baseline cool yeah yep
for your experience how often do toward
embeddings actually make it to
production yeah but if you employ search
engine they every time you need to
search for things which are say on a
lever lay two dogs
I like the later pads and you can you
can have different inventing switch for
dog its unless it can kick return cat or
they can turn different kinds of dogs so
it depends how we trained it not just
depends on the text if you did both so
how big is your context if you go far
away to find cat but if you already
closed probably find the different kinds
of dogs so if you have a dog and it
turns in a lab and Rottweiler and things
like that that that's cut you quite
useful in the search in the search
scenario but you mean sick like if you
have a supervised task you always have
you know some tests that and you have a
classifier and it's just a question of
what which features to feed to the
classifier do you give it just accounts
of how many times the word dog appears
or do P data vector for dog that's
that's when it helps but if you wanna do
a supervised task you have to have a
test set definitely but it used a lot in
classifying resumes you know like doing
corporate text search yeah it definitely
it has a lot of applications definitely
production yeah that's the question I
think somewhere yeah
yeah even though it's unsupervised
learning but I supervised learning it's
hard to find out how good it is you know
it just has this objective function you
know put the words that you're close
together together okay but I don't care
about working together I care about can
it tell me if it's a comedy another
comedy and so it's unsupervised I have
the super by stage where I have a bunch
of hyper parameters and then I have a
supervised stage later so it's you can
put it all into a grid search actually
like there's a skill learn interface
where you just like try different how
the parameters and find what's the best
thing there or you train them all to TA
they're that good like like key tf-idf
and LSI or just you know bag of words
and Lda this is also pretty good they're
all supervised techniques as well as
word embeddings making around for like
you know 10 years 15 years much longer
and I have this slide actually I'll do
the same thing but let me show you this
is some story cool yeah so it's all just
dimensionality reduction you know that's
always to go from this oh yeah here's
yeah
so the many other ways to get the vector
for a word basically you what do you
start with you start with matrix which
is told the collocation matrix
co-occurrence matrix I just have you
know oh you know folks and jump appear
in the same sentence ten times you know
the fans and folks appear in the same
context you know twenty times if you
have this matrix you know have ordered
them horizontally words vertically and
this is mathematics is really big it's
you know a million by million just for
kalabaw vocabulary so from that I want
to get some smaller representations and
how does to do that I have to factorize
the matrix and virtue like is one way to
factorize this matrix under some
condition and there are the ways to
factorize it you know like SVD let's say
I can just have a matrix factorized
bye-bye VDS you shouldn't think you know
I can do Lda which is a probabilistic
way to do this factorization or I can do
you know glove I can words were drowned
farm bed plus text yeah
there'll be talking on Sunday about fast
X and were drunk and work Tyvek you want
to know more about other embeddings yeah
okay well questionnaire
cool
well like there's a nice paper about how
to remove the biases from these
embeddings because gender biases racial
biases all the things it's like a hope
in a very nice published paper and you
know techniques how to remove the biases
you basically like say this or the vices
I'm looking for please remove them from
my model because you feed us in youth
and whatever is in the news gets into a
model and then I'm going to make
decisions and just perpetuates the bias
bias for that way huh it's just called
like removing biases from world of
innings it's actually I think it's a
major even yeah science I mean
uh-huh yeah that's the problem if you
don't know what you're looking for you
cannot you cannot take it out that is
that is specifically the problem you
have to define it before you can take
that bias out that is knowing today this
this people it basically said that this
this board should be analogous and this
like this analogy of example active CO
and co like that's that is a gender bias
and you should remove it and this is
specifically how you should adjust it to
remove it they have a specifically
positive example specifically suppose
for example and it's quite hard to find
out how good your unsupervised model is
like you can have a list of you have a
list of things like this and that's what
everybody in academia you know it's been
working with and there's other datasets
where they say like oh you know wardrobe
and food a similar in this way but
actually I've order up and put it
different in the other way because then
don't have the same function and they
have the different notions of similarity
and that's what they have to do like a
demon it's hard for them because you
don't have real and dutch/shell problems
you know in my case like if consultant
says you know classify movies I care
about specifically in the meaningful
classification of application of my
movies I said some bias in there I don't
really care because the and for
unfortunately yeah like I don't care
because it's if it's a bias in my data
said that all I need to do is get a good
accuracy to the bias if my movies
already labeled that way and that's
that's how it gets you know perpetuated
unfortunately but the only way you can
find out if your own models go to bed is
by a supervised task in the end by this
kind of yeah by looking at metrics like
this that's the only thing it tells me
if my model is good enough okay I'll
take a question
this I mean it's a if you take Spanish
Wikipedia and English Wikipedia and
their align them by like king and queen
and another like thousand points then
they're the same up to rotation that's
what they say so you can just like
rotate them and then if it's something
it's not in my aligned and in my
alignment then I can figure out you know
what what's the closest one another
space so yeah it's used much in
translation that way the only problem
with languages which are not English is
the morphology and yeah mythology is
really annoying because I run and
running at two different words in
English it's okay but like in Russian
like a run changes with the ways on
gender you know and yeah in Russian yeah
like an you know Portuguese it even it
has gender in Portuguese as well for
example the that's that's the main
problem of them is analogies so the
problem is much more apology how it
changes this fast text which is been
published by Facebook in August and it's
deal to analogous better but Sir it is a
morphology much better it's yeah I can
talk more about it on Sunday I keep
bitching its answer to your question
cool more questions yeah yeah if your
model changes a lot every time you train
it just by think you know every time we
train just fix data set that means we
don't have an app data it means you only
have you need to have much more data for
it to stabilize let's all have a small
alpha that's how you deal with
randomness but it should not happen like
for dr. Beck for example we have a have
a test where you know I do have doc one
which obtained through training then I
have doc one which I infer using this
gradual sign that I have to be the same
and that's what we do as a sign to check
off the model
so just means they had to have more data
if you have this jumpy and randomness
means they have to have more data that's
their usual answer to that
yeah like close enough like up to some
Epsilon yeah but talking about but to
use for Tyvek you really need like 500k
words what's the minimum you know just
needs more than that yeah four words
back yeah so maybe if you use like three
dimensional vectors you can probably do
it for like you know 50 words you just
use like you know if you only only need
to go is to go to three dimensions then
you sort of lose all your meaning and
that's why you can probably do with
tf-idf like something much simpler and
probably work if you have so so few
words in a vocabulary
yeah just more like if you want to go
from a million by Amelia metrics to like
100 by hundreds that's might be tough we
should go to like 500 by 500 that might
be there it's just a much challenged
action cool
yeah well as of time I think yeah I
would okay is anybody else who has a
question okay no more questions cool to
say yeah thank you
they'll have another talk on Sunday find
me on Twitter at Tigger milk or you know
come to us on github but yes student
talk to us about the student program
yeah thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]